do you think there is life beyond the
earth yes they do
why is that scientifically been proven
are we alone or is there life elsewhere
in the universe
this is a question humans have wondered
about for millennia and one that people
still have pretty strong opinions about
even though there isn't definitive
evidence to answer the question one way
or the other do you think that aliens
have ever come to earth people say that
there's like this being aliens in a
theme plants I forget what it's called
but they've like made these fields and
they've like produced something on on
the area 51 could be could be could be
possible it could be real you don't have
as area if you wanted all that kind of
stuff
I reckon they've got technology that
they operate out here you know do you
think it's technology that came from
aliens well possibly they could they
could be sharing information and game
technology for aliens on YouTube there
seems to be some pretty gum good
evidence about it but I don't know some
videos availa
they look convincing kinda yeah so the
Anunnaki apparently were beings that
came down from heaven according to the
old Sumerian text but the wall paintings
and stuff and um Sumeria Sumeria
I think people believe that aliens have
visited us just because they're not
aware of how vast the universe really is
I mean what is an exoplanet how far is a
Lightyear these are the things you need
to understand if you're to judge the
probability that alien life could come
and visit us what is a galaxy
specifically I wouldn't know is it
galaxy something totally different like
another universe maybe the galaxy has a
Sun and a moon is enough sir sir galaxy
is bigger than that
galaxies hundreds of stars in fact
hundreds of billions of billions of
stars yeah yeah what is it galaxy it's a
collection of stars and gas that are
held together in a gravitationally bound
system every point of light that you see
here is a star when we say 200 million
stars it's probably at least 200 billion
stars the galaxy is a hundred thousand
light years across so you know it's just
the distances are imagined unimaginable
one light year don't forget is 10
trillion kilometers what's a Lightyear
you're an engineer a Lightyear as a
thousand years is enough a Lightyear is
a thousand years isn't it about 150
human years would be a Lightyear it
would be alive that's what I believe it
would be the distance is a distance a
Lightyear have you heard the term
exoplanet no no exoplanets no like a
planet that we're not aware of well EXO
sugar could be short for so v
extraterrestrial final acts professor
your life may be something outside up in
it so an exoplanet is simply a planet
that orbits a star other than the Sun
EXO just means external outside so
outside our solar system so it's just a
planet you know you can how many have
you found me personally I found six but
overall we now know of over 800 planets
that have been confirmed and another
probably 2,000 planets that are awaiting
confirmation but are pretty strong
candidates so we don't see the planet
directly we see its impact on the star
that it orbits we do it from the ground
with a anglo-australian telescope and we
look for the wobble of the star as the
planet orbits the planet goes around and
the star moves backwards and forwards so
if you can imagine seeing that from sort
of along the line of sight a little bit
more say like in this in this cartoon
here then you would see the star moving
towards you and moving away from you and
so what we see here
the light from the star becoming ever so
slightly bluer as it moves towards us
and ever so slightly redder as it moves
away the big problem is that the main
kind of planet you end up finding with
this wobble technique because it's
really reliant on the mass of the planet
basically like Jupiter Saturn and then
we've started to get down to Neptune and
Uranus to find smaller planets NASA
launched Kepler a 1 meter telescope with
a 95 megapixel camera its mission is to
observe a hundred and thirty thousand
stars in our galaxy and look for dips
and brightness caused by planets passing
in front of them so Kepler 62 is a Sol
system with five planets and the planets
are very similar in size to the
terrestrial planets the rocky planets in
our own solar system so have the star in
the middle then you have three inner
planets there's a green band which is
this habitable zone the Goldilocks zone
where you can expect liquid water to
exist on the surface of the planet and
in fact there are two planets inside the
habitable zone around Kepler 62 if
you're going to start looking for life
around nearby stars this is probably the
best one to start with is there a life
beyond the earth well we don't know for
sure we can't say yes definitely but the
probability is very high there are at
least 200 billion stars in our galaxy we
now know that on average there is at
least one planet per star in our galaxy
alone and there are another 100-plus
billion galaxies in the universe we also
now know thanks to the Kepler spacecraft
that at least one in six of those is
earth size and so that's 33 billion
potential earth sized planets not all of
them are going to be able to have life
but the probability of getting pretty
high already at this stage so there is
no definitive evidence that alien life
exists but the sheer size of the numbers
suggests that they must be out there
somewhere but with the vast distances
across the universe chances are it's
going to be a long time before we know
for certain that we are not alone this
video was created as part of a
collaboration addressing 10 unanswered
science questions so subscribe to
veritasium and then check out the other
nine questions by clicking the link
okay is there more than one galaxy out
there and yeah probably how many would
you say I couldn't tell you it's
probably more than on my tent and
fingers I guess it's more than 100
billion on the boat in probably it's
crazy yeah